so what is your formula
in helping businesses see those
entrepreneurs come up with their stories
well before i get into the formula i
will say for me
as i look at businesses you know there
are traditionally three p's that you
have to get right you have to get your
product right
and when your product is is wanted in
the market and profitable
you've got to start hiring people and
who knew we needed a counseling degree
to run a business but
it's definitely beneficial you got to
get your people straight
and then if you want to scale you have
to get your processes straight
and a lot of people they neglect the
fourth p and the fourth p
is positioning how are we positioning
ourselves in the market what words are
we using to stick in people's minds and
differentiate
ourselves from the competition the
beautiful thing about positioning
is it doesn't cost a lot of money it's
almost free it's literally just words
you've got to sit down and do some
really hard work on a napkin
and figure out how you're going to talk
about your product or service
businesses that figure out that fourth p
that position themselves in the market
tend to skyrocket the truth is people
don't actually buy the best products and
services they buy the ones that they can
understand the fastest if if somebody
can hear about your product and only a
few words
and and connect the idea that it will
help them solve a problem
you are much more likely to buy that
product
so when i developed this formula and the
formula is based on
ancient story structure when i developed
the formula for clarifying your message
the purpose of that formula
was to to leave uh with a messaging
system that would position you in the
marketplace that would be a competitive
advantage
excellent so that's that's why i
developed the formula in the first place
i love it so before we get into the
positioning how about we stay on this
four piece here real quick for a second
product people process positioning so
most people
you know i think you would agree that uh
say they have a great product and just
because they have a great product they
think they're going to make it to the
top and you and i both know product
alone won't do it you need to have a
real marketing plan behind it
so let's talk about people because i you
said counselor
uh when you're talking about people
unpack what that means to you is it
recruiting is it developing people
is it the culture is it how to lift them
up
is it how to get them to work together
what does people mean to you
all of the above uh really for a small
business owner they've got to figure out
who they're going to hire next
and for me that order was a virtual
assistant who could duplicate my time
and then
somebody who could help me run the
company i tend to be creative
i'm a visionary i'm a content creator
and i'm a strategist
i'm not a details person i'm not going
to go and figure out a contract with
whoever i need other people
to do that so for me after i had a
virtual assistant i had to do a pretty
good analysis of what my liabilities are
not what my strengths are what my
liabilities are and then i needed
i need to be honest about that and admit
i'm not a details person
uh and i've got to figure out i've got
to find somebody to help me figure out
the administrative part i'm not
i do not want to spend a week
researching best health care plans for
my team
i want somebody to come and present to
me a few plans and then i approve one of
them
so i you you have to hire your
weaknesses
uh and staff those out so everybody's
hiring tree or hiring plan should
actually be a little bit different
and then the the people who i want to
hire have some common characteristics
patrick and i think you'll appreciate
them
there are about 10 of them but i'll give
you the top three
the first is i want to hire human beings
who actually see themselves as an
economic product on the open market
and what i mean by that is they see
themselves as an investment and they
give people a return on that investment
so if i'm gonna pay you fifty thousand
dollars a year i want somebody who says
if you're gonna pay me fifty thousand
dollars a year
i wanna make you and likewise
if i make you a hundred thousand dollars
you know a million dollars a year i
would like to be paid a hundred thousand
so there's this constant negotiation
back and forth where we're having an
honest assessment of what you're
bringing into the company and what your
economic value is
now god sees you as priceless i see you
as priceless your spouse sees you as
priceless your kid sees your price
that's priceless
but the business world sees you as an
economic investment and so i want people
who really understand that
they don't want to just be paid to sit
behind a desk or to show up from nine to
five
and park their hair and have and not
have bad breath right
i want somebody who says i'm a stock and
when you invest in me i'm going to give
you a giant return
which is exactly how you and i have to
see ourselves as the ceo of the company
if
a customer invests in me they're
investing in me to get a
ton of money back that's the only way my
business can grow
and you know andrew grove former ceo
over at intel
you know he said everybody is their own
company and you're constantly competing
with everybody else
and so i like people who see themselves
that way the second
characteristic i like is somebody who
will who really it's very hard for them
to position themselves as a victim
they don't go to victim mode very easily
they stay with that hero energy and love
attacking obstacles
and overcoming challenges so when i hear
victims speak
i tend i tend to think those people
aren't going to fit on my staff
and then the third you'll also
appreciate patrick i like a team member
who de-escalates drama
drama i think saps everybody's energy uh
it's no fun to deal with drama i love it
when there's a dramatic situation and
somebody can come in
and and de-escalate that drama so it's
smooth sailing
if i hire people with those three
characteristics i can teach them almost
anything